One of the most poorly titled movies of all
time, The First Purge, invalidated 5 years
of me referring to THIS movie as the first
Purge. However, unlike the original Purge,
this one came out relatively close to when
the story takes place. The movie is set in
2016 and if you want to see me explain the
timeline watch this video.
But being set closer to the release date affords
this movie an interesting opportunity to incorporate
current events for the first time. Like how
Isaiah has a poster for another poorly titled
movie: Halloween 2018 in his room. This is
part advertising for Blumhouse who wanted
to hype up their other big release for that
year, and part foreshadowing, as Isaiah and
his loved ones would hide in a closet at the
end of the movie, just like Laurie Strode
did in Halloween.
To learn about the other references and hidden
meanings in The First Purge, stick around
to the end of this video.
There aren’t really any decent masks for
sale for The First Purge for whatever reason,
so I’m gonna go bare for this one. Welcome to Things You
Missed. The initial three Purge films were
both written and directed by James Demonaco,
but for this prequel, he’d stay on as screenwriter
while tasking Gerard McMurray with directing
duties.
Subtle is probably not the word best used
to describe any Purge film, but you could
at least make the argument that the themes
are subtle in 1 through 3, especially if you’ve
seen my videos analysing them. McMurray decided
to take a more direct approach.
The poster for this movie and the line said
during this one scene are very obvious jabs
at the United States White House administration
during the time the movie was made, whereas
the previous movies depicted the NFFA as an
alternative to real life political parties.
As you know, we’re not here to talk about
the most obvious details in this movie, we’re
here to talk about the Things You Missed.
So let’s get into the Things You Missed.
Here’s the Things You Missed screen.
One detail I found interesting was how the
NFFA Chief of Staff intentionally sends his
mercenaries to purge in low-income areas.
This makes it appear as if the lower class
is out for blood, which almost directly leads
into the beginning of the original movie,
where a group of affluent purgers hunt down
an innocent homeless man for no other reason
than the fact that he is homeless.
We’ve also seen that the NFFA likes to use
statistics to make it seem like The Purge
is helping reduce crime during the rest of
the year. Unfortunately, the NFFA website,
which was updated with statistics and additional
lore to promote Purge movie releases in the
past has its weakest iteration for The First
Purge -- there’s basically no new information
here.
But perhaps more importantly, at the beginning
of the movie, we see how this data was skewed.
The scene suggests they are doing their research
about crime behaviour using crazies and addicts,
as opposed to the general population. This
is a tactic they use to craft their own narrative.
They want to make it seem The Purge is the
answer for the nation’s problems, but many
of their opposers see through the BS and protest
at the sign up stations, where citizens can
volunteer to participate in The Purge Experiment
in exchange for financial compensation. The
conflict draws in many news stations, including
one called KRXJ News, a station that has also
appeared in the TV show Psyche and in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
It seems it's appeared in a couple of other shows as well.
Is this a coincidence?
I don’t think so.
There are about 35,000 possible combinations
that start with either K or W. I tried Googling
a number of random combinations, and surprisingly,
they all seem to be taken. But KRXJ was the
only one I found that yielded a fictional
entity.
After doing a little digging, I realized that
prop designer Daniel Columbie has also designed
for a few Marvel movies. I’m guessing that’s
the connection, and the answer to this pointless
question.
The sign up stations also give away blue flowers
to those who sign up to participate.
“Baptisias. The official flower of the experiment.
They represent rebirth.”
This explains the origin of a through line
in each of the Purge movies: the baptisias, which
became a sign of support for the Purge.
STRANGER: “And your blue flowers tell me
that you support The Purge.”
The main antagonist this time is the original
NFFA Chief of Staff, Arlo Sabian. If you’ve
seen my other Purge episodes, you know that
Sabian is a name that comes up in every Purge
movie, which is perhaps just a symptom of
the fact that they are all written by James
Demonaco, who likes to have a character named
Sabian in all of his work.
The other James Demonaco trademark is Staten
Island, where the Purge experiment is going
to take place. This location appears on a
TV screen in preceding Purge movies,
and the two non-Purge movies he’s directed
are both set there.
But not far from where this is taking place, our
main character, Nya, leads a protest against
the controversial experiment. One of the signs
reads “The 28th is a h*te crime”. This
suggests that The Purge is being considered
as the 28th Amendment to the US Constitution,
which is confirmed in the original iteration
of the website.
But I think this movie creates an interesting
metaphor for The Constitution. Nya and Isaiah
live at a building called The Park Towers.
Let’s pretend that building is The US Constitution.
It’s an old building. It has a lot of leaks
that have come up over the years. The people
that live there have a lot of issues with
it. The problem is, the manager is never in,
and isn’t much help anyway with fixing these
issues anyways.
Our characters are minorities, and they live
on the 14th floor. It just so happens that
the 14th Amendment deals with equal protection
of the laws, and is often used to fight racial
discrimination.
This is fitting, because the NFFA hires modern
factions of racist groups such as the KKK
and Aryan Nations to go into Staten Island
and purge. The main bad guy, whose name is…
General Smiley?.. Has a gold armband very
similar to the red Nazi armband you might
see in generals wearing in old photographs.
They attack the entire building floor by floor.
On the second floor, a couple of armed citizens
fight back against them. As it turns out,
the second amendment is the right to bear
arms, something citizens are reminded of in
the form of a huge billboard. The text at
the bottom says “Paid for by the UARO Political
Victory Fund. I have no idea what the UARO
is, but if you look up “political victory
fund” you’ll find a bunch of stuff about
the NRA, who are stated at the beginning of
the movie to be supporting the New Founding
Fathers.
“The New Founding Fathers, rising in polls,
with the NRA now endorsing them and supporting
them financially with large donations to the
NFFA warchest.”
The implication is that The Purge is fueled
by money, that this whole thing happened because
the NFFA values money, more than it values
the lives of its citizens.
“They have monetized and incentivized murder.
Walk away from their money!”
The police officers who are keeping an eye
on this protest don’t seem too enthused,
but names like “Forbes” and “Sachs”,
maybe it’s because they are in on it as well.
Staten Island was chosen as the site of the
experiment partially because it is home to
a number of street gangs, one of which is
led by a man named Dmitri who surprisingly
operates out of a community center named after
Jamaican activist Marcus Garvey.
You’ve probably noticed that this movie
picks up where Election Year left off comparing
the anti-Purge movement to the American Civil
Rights movement. The First Purge is, as usual,
a lot less subtle about it; there’s one
point where Nya even claims that she sees
The Purge as a way the government is trying
to keep minorities down. In Election Year,
Joe’s Deli was the center of the community,
and it displayed the photos of several Civil
Rights leaders.
In The First Purge, the community center has
some of these same photos. Literally, we see
the same exact picture for Martin Luther King
Jr and a very similar picture for Malcolm X. I don’t know if this was
the production just trying to save a few bucks
on props, but it actually makes me wonder
if Joe from Election Year might have been
a youngster at this very community center,
and took these photos with him when he went
to DC to start the deli.
We know he has been a part of gang activity
before.
“Told you I ain’t no saint. Everybody’s
got a past.”
The other photos include civil rights figures:
Jesse Jackson, Marcus Garvey, Thurgood Marshall;
and the corkboard celebrates athletes who
broke the color barrier, like Jesse Owens,
Mohammed Ali and Jackie Robinson. Robinson
came up with the Brooklyn Dodgers playing
first base, but faced a lot of adversity because
he was the first African American-American
to play in MLB, as opposed to the Negro Leagues.
Brooklyn is right next to Staten Island, and
there’s a scene later in the film where
a black man is purged by white police officers
just in front of first base at a
stadium with advertisements for The Purge
experiment displayed in the outfield. So it
feels like the movie is telling us that The
Purge gave bad people the opportunity to undo
the progress made by people like Jackie Robinson.
And while we’re talking about sports, I
have to say that there was a huge missed
opportunity by the wardrobe department. They
gave this guy, Taz, an Eli Manning jersey.
But they should have given him #17 for Plaxico
Burress, seeing as how Taz later gets shot
in the leg, and Plaxico Burress infamously
shot himself in the leg at a nightclub.
Gotta love the character of Dmitri though,
I mean how many powerful gangsters have time
to also be an inspiring community basketball
coach? When it comes to gangsters named Dmitri,
this guy is probably in my top 2 or 3.
In Dmitri’s office, he has a giant artwork
of Ben Franklin, as seen on the 100 dollar
bill. In universe, the reason he has it simply
because he likes money, but there are many
shots where the eye peeks through, as if it
is watching and spying on him.
Ben Franklin is one of America’s original
founding fathers, and in the film, the government
is controlled by a party called the New Founding
Fathers, and they are notorious for spying
on the citizens, whether it be through surveillance
cameras, recording contact lenses or attack
drones.
Another symbol for this can be seen in the
party scene, where a giant eyeball is passed
around in the crowd.
The party goers wear animal masks and makeup,
such as foxes, lions, leopards and cows. I
think I spotted a wendigo in there too. This
is a way of foreshadowing the predator prey
relationship between the NFFA and the public.
And speaking of masks, there’s a scene where
Nya is trapped by a guy with a creepy baby
doll mask. The repurposing of a baby doll
seems to be a nod to the remote control camera
created by Charlie Sandin in the original
Purge.
“Quit playing with Timmy and come help me
set the table, Kiddo”
Since this is a prequel, there are some things
that we’ve come to know about the world
of The Purge that seemingly haven’t been
instituted yet. I noticed that the vehicles
have New York license plates, where in later
entries, the NFFA have instituted a uniform
license plate for the US that says “A Nation
Reborn.”
This was also before the US Postal Service
was replaced with NFFA Mail.
Another difference is that the color of the
emergency broadcast screen was red instead
of the usual blue. Director Gerard McMurray
kind of flipped the script when it comes to
color. Other than this one graphic at the
very end of Election Year, the NFFA is always
associated with the color blue. Perhaps the
NFFA intentionally chose light blue so that
the public associates them with the good guys.
Think about pop culture: good guys blue, bad
guys red.
But McMurray uses light in this movie to reveal
the true allegiances of characters. In addition
to the red emergency broadcast, there’s
the NFFA headquarters, the hunters that try
to purge Isaiah, and Sabian steps into the
red light after revealing the true sinister
intentions of the experiment.
Isaiah has blue contacts, Nya’s church is
blue, and Dmitri’s car has a blue underglow.
Dmitri’s office is also blue, but when the
assassins enter the room, they come from the
lone red light in the corner.
The office also has a picture of a man in
red boxing against a man in blue; The Purge
is like a punch in the face from the government
to those that oppose them.
Interestingly, Skeletor is the only character
whose contact lenses are purple, a combination
of red and blue. The bystanders who stay home
are green, and the looters are usually green
and occasionally orange.
It’s possible that there’s also a political
side to McMurray’s decision to color code.
In the US, Green is representative of the
third party, so maybe that’s why green is
used to portray those that seem to be neutral.
The artwork in Dmitri’s office is also representative
of the differing ways that Nya and Dmitiri
deal with their problems. In one scene, Nya
confronts him because she was upset that her
younger brother was getting involved in his
operation. She criticizes him for what his
gang has done to their community. As they
argue, Dmitri is standing in front of the
two boxers -- he solves his problems with
aggression.
The artwork behind Nya also depicts a boxer,
but he is sitting in the dark, thinking and
quietly reflecting. Nya solves her issues
with her head.
Isaiah had been hurt while selling illegal
substances on the street for Dmitri. Nya is
vocally against him him doing this, and their
apartment is covered with signage that says
“Drug Free Zone” and “No Smoking”.
Dimitri’s gangs rule the streets, but the
apartment acts as a safe haven for Isaiah.
I also noticed that their building looks very
similar to the example of low-income housing
that Dante Bishop shows on TV during Election
Year. Election Year takes place 24 years later,
so these images illustrate how nothing ever
actually improved while the NFFA was in power.
Comparing the technology from The First Purge
to Election Year highlights one of the many
frustrating things about The Purge franchise
-- which is that technology actually seems
to get worse as time goes on. Election Year
has a lot of tech that feels old even today.
The coolest gadget in the series is probably
The First Purge’s video contact lenses,
which are actually based on a real concept
that Sony has filed patents for, but we are
still years and years away from seeing in
practice as I record this video in 2021.
Now I’m gonna get to the end of the movie,
and why it makes no sense, but before I do,
it’s that part of the video, where I’ve
gotta air them out a little bit. During the
robbery at this cash for gold place, why does
the store owner only have a security shade
over one window? And I like how he keeps his
neon signs on, so he can advertise to criminals
that he has valuables.
Also, there’s no way Dmitri would have survived
this crash, but he’s perfectly fine a couple
minutes later?
One thing I did find interesting is that the
mercenaries that Sabian sent into the Purge
to give the appearance that people had participated
are hidden in everyday vehicles, like a plumber’s
truck and a veteran transport van.
Now the ending of the movie is a bit unconventional.
With Dmitri’s help, Nya, Isaiah and the
others are able to ward off General Smiley,
Skeletor and the rest of the bad guys, and
The Purge ends.
Usually at the end of the movie, you see that
the character has changed somehow. We call it: character
arc. But when Nya asks Dmitri what’s next
he tells her:
“Now we fight.”
Which kind of goes against the message of
the movie, which has shown us how fighting
basically nearly destroyed the community.
So it’s kind of like a “bad guys win anyway”
scenario, because conflict is exactly what
the NFFA wants.
This ending also might be suggesting that
Dmitri was kind of like the start of the resistance,
kind of a seed that would grow into the anti-NFFA
group that we meet later on in The Purge Anarchy,
as more people in different cities get involved.
That group is probably not the most notable
resistance in the Purge franchise though,
I would give that honor to the group we see
in another poorly titled installment, The
Purge TV series. So join me in the next episode
of Things You Missed, where I’ll be breaking
down the entire show. Remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell and select ALL notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one. Assuming
we both survive. If you don’t want to be
purged stay home. If you go out for essentials,
wear a mask.